this is me and I love coffee the
intoxicating nutty aroma the rich
chocolatey taste some days I drink three
cups like the average American I am
other it is I drink more like five or
six but is that too much first the good
news it's almost impossible to overdose
on coffee there is a lethal dose of
caffeine but it's somewhere around 10
grams and the average cup of joe has
around 100 milligrams so you likely have
to drink a hundred cups in rapid
succession to OD but that's not to say
there's no such thing as too much the
FDA recommends no more than four to five
cups a day for the average healthy adult
more than that and you might start to
experience some nasty side effects you
know most people taking a hot coffee for
you know to increase their focus and the
concentration once you start you know
taking in too much while you start
losing that focus people start getting
more agitated irritable that's thanks to
the hormone adrenaline when caffeine
hits your system it stimulates your
adrenal glands which release the hormone
into your body it makes you feel
energetic and alert perfect for a fight
or flight situation but too much can be
a bad thing especially if you suffer
from anxiety but with anxiety you also
want to be careful not to you know over
stimulated or trigger any sort of panic
attacks or you know make things
anxiety worse which certainly too much
caffeine can do adrenaline from caffeine
can also increase your heart rate that's
why doctors often recommend against
drinking coffee if your heart sometimes
beats irregularly but the risk is really
only for bona fide coffee junkies
according to at least two observational
studies you have to drink at least nine
cups of coffee a day to put yourself at
risk of arrhythmia and finally there's
the question of sleep
coffee's enemy caffeine launches a
double threat on your slumber it blocks
the neurochemical adenosine which is
what tells your brain that you're tired
it releases a cocktail of stimulants
into your brain adrenaline dopamine and
glutamate so after downing your sixth
cup of coffee you don't just feel awake
but full of energy it will power you
through that 2:30 meeting or the last
class of the day but if you overdo it
the effect won't wear off when it's time
for bed in one study researchers
monitored the sleep of a dozen
volunteers some are given a caffeine
pill equivalent to about four cups of
coffee and others received a placebo
instead even when the volunteers
swallowed the caffeine pill six hours
before bedtime
they spent significantly less time in
the light stages of sleep I'm not gonna
have detrimental effects on daytime
function the author's report it's sort
of like it's just stuck in this little
in this loop where you're not sleeping
because you drink too much coffee and
then you wake up in the morning and
you're you're not well-rested and then
you're drinking more coffee just to say
week two in a day sound familiar here's
the good news
if you cut yourself off by two o'clock
you typically won't have trouble falling
asleep that's because the half-life of
caffeine is around five hours and so
most of its stimulating effects will
wear off well before the lights go out
and if you also limit your consumption
well then coffee can actually offer a
number of health benefits research shows
that it can help with everything from
memory to exercise to your relationships
with your colleagues and that's great
because for some of us coffee is
something we'll just never give up
you